we're heading into 2017 and a new
production year we are counting down the
five most viewed videos new videos from
2016 on the david pakman show YouTube
channel of course many of the most
viewed videos of the year are not new
videos from 2016 but we're what we're
going to look at here to wrap things up
for 2016 the most viewed new videos of
2016 starting with number five the
number five most viewed video of the
year is reza aslan cannot be trusted our
investigation into the various claims
made by reza aslan the fifth most viewed
video of the year
the number four most viewed video of
2016 is trump forgets cameras exist says
black people are uneducated poor and
jobless just over six hundred thousand
views they're the third most viewed a
new video of 2016 on the david pakman
show YouTube channel is Trump caught
knowing nothing
mumbles words salad yes this was this
was one of my favorite videos of of 2016
closer to seven hundred thousand views
there what was that one about he was
asked I don't remember what he was asked
about but he just basically mumbled
talking points and buzzwords a very very
quietly during the interview
communicating nothing it was a Sarah
Palin like attempt to use language to
communicate anything with meaning I'll
have to check out that video and thus
give it one more view yes one more view
is going to come from Pat before the
years out the number two second most
viewed video of 2016 just under a
million views called Sarah Palin loses
it when asked about blaming Obama for
her son beating his girlfriend
yes that one was quite controversial in
Sarah Palin even though it has been a
year since she destroyed anybody's
candidacy for president still getting
the views on YouTube during 2016 and
finally the number one most viewed new
video of 2016 on the David Pakman show
YouTube channel is with over 1 million
views embarrassing Trump audio expose
is him as totally clueless Wow Wow
that's it that wraps up 2016 for us in
terms of the most viewed videos on to
2017 remember to subscribe to the
YouTube channel